Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Supernatural Crowley got something of an
intervention and Dean finally got his hands
on the First Blade.
Alaina Huffman was absent, but she left a
very notable calling card on the baby.
Seriously, I couldn’t tell if Dean was more
upset by that or about the First Blade.
Quick heads up too, next week’s episode,
“Mother’s Little Helper” is directed
by Misha Collins.
I’m back on my normal schedule.
So be sure to subscribe to get my video for
that.
I’ll post it Wednesday Morning.
So about half of this episode was Leaving
Las Vegas and Half National Treasure.
So I’m going to do my top 5 moments and
then my review.
It’s kind of a mixture of visual gags and
action.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Crowley’s Sex, Pizza and Human
Blood bender.
If you’ve never seen Leaving Las Vegas it’s
a movie where Nicolas Cage decides to slowly
drink himself to death over a weekend in Vegas
and hires Elisabeth Shue, a hooker.
To hang out with him while he does it.
That movie is a really intense drama, but
it was all I could think about during this
in between laughs.
It really is like he’s just an aging rockstar
heroin junkie.
Number 4 - Crowley’s Intervention.
I loved Dean barking in Crowley’s face.
Like he was going to yell him sober.
It also reminded me of the Dog Dean episode.
I feel like I missed the addictive aspect
of blood in the previous episodes.
I always knew he enjoyed it, but I didn’t
know that human blood had the same side effects
as a human taking intraveous drugs.
The way Crowley played it up, it made it seem
like Human blood, for him, was like heroin
laced acid with some cocaine sprinkled on
top.
Just to make it extra addictive.
Number 3 - Snooki at the Crossroads
I hate Snooki, but I will confess that this
was funny.
Especially the implication first that she
was only famous because she was getting fringe
benefits from working for Crowley and two,
that before they left, they exorcised the
demon inside her.
Teasing that Snooki wouldn’t be famous anymore
now that there wasn’t a demon possessing
her.
I’m all for the Winchesters performing a
Snooki exorcism on all our televisions.
Just make her go away.
Forever.
Number 2 - First Blade National Treasure
This was everything up to the point of Deputy
Andy from Eureka going all creepy.
I loved the Men of Letters lore and the Mad
Science spell aspect of this.
Way more interesting than the Crowley as Junkie
story.
When he said he had a Zoo in his pocket dimension
house, I instantly thought of The Island of
Doctor Moreau.
Part of me is wondering now if he was using
spells to try and mess with Demon DNA.
Although, if they’re ethereal beings, maybe
they don’t have DNA?
Deep Monster Thoughts.
You could have done an entire episode inside
his house though.
Just think of all the powerful relics he had
collected.
It’s like Sam and Dean should combine all
the knowledge and spells from the Men of Letters
Bunker with all the weapons from Cuthbert’s
collection.
They’d have everything they need to fight
a war against rogue Angels and Abaddon’s
demons.
Although I guess all you really need is Dean
and the First Blade.
and my number one Moment - Dean Activates
the First Blade
They’ve kept on teasing us with this “price”
that you have to pay to wield the blade.
And based on Dean’s reaction to it, I think
we can assume that it just puts you into a
killing frenzy where you just tune out mentally
and can’t distinguish friend from foe.
Meaning, Dean could potentially end up killing
Castiel accidentally if he’s around when
Dean tries to kill Abaddon.
Or he could accidentally kill Sam.
Based on the teaser for the next episode,
it seems like their brotherly tension is reaching
boiling point.
Now it’s your turn though.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and do you think that the Blade is going to
make Dean accidentally kill Sam or Castiel?
If you didn’t catch it, there were two Stargate
Atlantis and Eureka Cameos.
This is filmed in Vancouver, so actors are
bound to show up on shows together all the
time.
Sheriff Andy, was Major Lorne and Dean Marshall
was Sargeant Bradley on Stargate and he was
also Doctor Herrerra on Eureka.
I love Vancouver shows.
This happens a lot with Battlestar Galactica
actors too.
Overall I gave the episode a B, just because
I really was not digging the Crowley Junkie
Plot.
I’m really just referring to the resolution.
I love the idea that he’s addicted to Human
Blood.
But I felt like we didn’t need fifty percent
of this episode.
They could have just spent the entire time
in this amazing National Treasure-esque house.
There were just way too many teasers for magical
items we did not get to see.
It would be like Harry Potter if they never
explored Hogwarts.
Just a criminal misuse of a magical museum.
I did love everything to do with the First
Blade.
Especially those music cues that swelled when
Dean picked it up.
I wonder if that plot will mirror the Human
Blood Crowley plot.
And Dean will get addicted to the emotions
the Blade gives him.
I feel like they were implying that it gives
the bearer equal feelings of invincibility
and murderous rage.
Just like drugs.
Although Crowley’s drugs seemed more euphoric.
Next week Alaina Huffman is back, which makes
me happy.
Abbadon is cool, but I love Alaina Huffman.
Let me know what you thought of the episode
and if you thought of Sheriff Andy when you
saw Cuthbert.
I’ll try to post next week’s Supernatural
by Wednesday Morning.
My schedule is slowly getting back to normal.
Right now click here for my last supernatural
episode and click here to learn about my top
10 Doctor Who Monsters for Series 8.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!